Well, GBT 5 is here and it's in the free
tier. I've tested it a bunch, read the
system card in full, and even sat
through that full live stream. Wow. But
actually, I think it's pretty huge that
free users of ChatBT will get access to
GPT5. In other words, approaching a
billion people will experience a
significantly more intelligent AI model,
at least before they hit the limits. But
if you watched the live stream and demo,
you may have been underwhelmed. And I
don't just mean the mathematically
impossible bar graphs, and there were
multiple of those. There were even
hallucinations in the segment describing
how the model hallucinates less. For
sure, it would be easy to make a video
just taking the mick of those mistakes.
But the thing is, GT5 is actually a
pretty great model. So, here are my
first impressions. First, my own logic
benchmark or some people call it a trick
question benchmark. I can confirm that
GT5 indeed does crush the public
questions of SimpleBench. Whoever this
was that came out with this viral thread
of it getting 9 out of 10 on those
public 10 questions from SimpleBench
wasn't lying. Technically, in some of my
early testing, it got questions right
that no other model had gotten right.
When I saw this, I was like, man, I'm
gonna have to bring out V2 really early.
Everyone's going to get super hyped.
This is crazy. However, if you're newer
to AI, you might not know that the
performance of language models is
heavily dependent on the training data
they're fed. And I suspect some of these
10 public questions have made it into
the training data, at least indirectly.
Not deliberately, I think, but given
that the models are trained on things
like Reddit and other forums, it's
definitely not impossible. Given how
long I normally take to update the
leaderboard, you guys might be quite
shocked to hear that we're doing the
runs tonight. And so far, it's not
setting a new record. That surprised
even me actually. I was expecting
honestly 70%. I'll be honest with you
guys. So far in the three runs we've
done it's getting around 57 58%. So at
this point we can be clear it's not a
new paradigm of AI and if you didn't
believe models were AGI now this model
won't convince you that we have AGI but
in fairness to OpenAI just a couple of
hours ago Samman tweeted that they could
release much much smarter models but the
main thing they were pushing for was
real world utility which I'm going to
come to and mass accessibility and
affordability well they have delivered
on that when it comes to affordability
in the API the Prices are incredible
below clawed force on it. For those who
care about the API, I've got some coding
data coming up. But first,
hallucinations. The team made a big play
about how GC5 would hallucinate less
than previous models. Quite early on in
the system card, which is as good a
research paper as we're going to get, it
seems. They say that we find that GT5
main has 44% fewer responses with at
least one major factual error. However,
I got suspicious immediately when on the
live stream I saw a bunch of new
benchmarks rather than the ones we
already know. I don't blame anyone
watching for not knowing this, but one
of the most quoted benchmarks on
hallucinations is simple QA. These are
short factual questions that can be
prone to hallucinations. And on that
front, GPT5 thinking is just about
better than 03 maybe if you squint.
Obviously, it makes it hard to compare
if we invent a new benchmark for every
single model release. But it's probably
fair to say it does hallucinate a bit
less. Again, though, if you don't follow
AI too closely, this model, just as all
the others, will still hallucinate with
a major incorrect claim around 5% of the
time. These are on the questions, by the
way, that users are actually using
chatbt for. Okay, now for one domain
that OpenAI really did want to
highlight, which is software engineering
and one benchmark in particular,
SweetBench verified. This time, by the
way, you'll notice that the graph
doesn't have 52% as being higher than
69%. This for me then is one of the
bigger developments with GT5 because in
software engineering essentially OpenAI
lobbed a grenade at Anthropic. They want
the Clawude family line to die out
without heirs because SweetBench
verified is the singular benchmark that
Anthropic cited as proof that their
newest model 4.1 Opus just a few days
old was the frontier model in this
domain. If we completely ignore
statistical error bars, GPT5 is now
better. Fair warning, if you are not
into coding or even Vibe coding, this
video won't spend too long on it.
straight away within cursor, I did
notice the difference. I'm not going to
show my codebase right now, so let's
just leave this other coding benchmark
on screen. But testing GC5 versus for
set, the best model you get by default
from anthropic on cursor and GC5 was
just better finding bugs that Sonet
assured me were not there. Obviously, we
need more time to test and there's
always the black horse of Gemini deep
think which I think might be the best of
all, but Anthropic get a lot of revenue
from Vibe coders and professional
developers. So, GT5's release could be a
challenging time for Anthropic. Now, I
know it was a very hypy statement from
the live stream, but I do actually get
it when one of the presenters said he
trusts the model more with coding. Of
course, language models live and die by
data. So, if G65 lacks it in your
domain, it will be jank. So do test
things out yourself. Beyond coding
though, if you are asking a technical
question that might rely on an image,
GT5 is looking real good. Take the mmu
which includes a ton of charts and
tables. And here GT5 is beating the
massively slower and much more
inaccessible Gemini Deepthink, which is
currently reserved for the addicts
forking out $250 a month. Yes, I was
disappointed that the context window has
been barely widened. Man, we need some
fresh air in here. What I mean is I love
that Gemini 2.5 Pro can analyze 1
million tokens or almost a million
words, but we are stuck in the low
hundreds of thousands for GPT5. Next,
you may have noticed on the live stream
Sebastian Bubck, one of the lead authors
of that famous Sparks of AGI paper about
GPT4 and one of the first viewers of
this channel actually 2 and a half years
ago. He described the quote recursive
self-improvement to be had when models
can produce better synthetic data that
is then used to train the next
generation of models. I do get that for
getting epic scores on benchmarks. But
if that was all it took, then models
like 54 and the openweight OpenAI GPTO
OSS model would be demiggods by now
given how heavily they were trained on
synthetic data. True story, that recent
OpenAI open weight model flopped so
badly on SimpleBench that OpenAI reached
out to me personally to ask about our
settings, which were the standard ones,
by the way. A bit later on, I'm going to
go to the biggest bit of anti-hype you
could find. But a few new people may be
watching tonight. So, let's touch on
another highly usable aspect, amazing
aspect of GBC 5. If you watched the live
stream and thought those Vibe coding
demos were epic, they were. And don't
let addicts like us tell you otherwise.
Because snake games and chart displays
are everywhere in the training data.
That's why GC5 can bang them out with
ease. Building a production ready
consumer app is a very different story
for now. So I would say we don't quite
have what Samman quoted tonight,
software on demand, but we may be slowly
getting there. More on that in another
video coming out soon. Back to the
system card and they kept talking about
health journeys and though I had never
heard that expression, it didn't strike
me that they were taking us for a ride.
For me, it's genuinely incredible and it
will be super impactful that you can
often get expert level textbased
diagnosis from these models. Notice I
say you can often get that. Though I
don't think many people will have
noticed this one that GT5 mini scored
higher on healthbench consensus than GT5
itself. I can imagine some frantic users
on the free tier waiting until their GT5
allowance is out to get the quote better
model on health. Now, just in case
there's any really confused people
watching, if you're wondering, there's
no new Sora or image generator. There
are, however, new voices. And for those
who've been chatting on the free tier
with models quite a lot, you should
notice a step up in conversation
quality. Although, I was disappointed
that GT5's language skills have not
improved from 03. Translation, I feel,
is such an unmititigated good from AI. I
was hoping that they had been able to
push the frontier a bit harder. Some of
you will be asking about the semi-
mythical GPT5 Pro. And yes, I'd love to
test it. I am on the pro tier, but I'm
not yet seeing it in my app as of
tonight. So soon hopefully. Probably
isn't crazily better than the other
types of GT5 given they barely mentioned
it in the presentation. Now though for
the real anti-hype because even one of
the lead authors of AI 2027 which took
the world by storm and was read by
millions. Well the headlines or videos
derived from were seen or read by
millions that Eli Lifeland said that he
noticed from the system card no
improvement on the coding evals that
weren't Swebench. Translated you know
all those videos you've been seeing on
YouTube about AI taking over the world
within the next 2 years. Well, one of
the authors behind that who I
interviewed on Patreon has probably
updated in the negative in terms of his
timelines. We should be seeing a bit
more self-improvement by now if those
timelines were accurate. It makes sense,
right? We would need to see significant
improvement from GPT5 on machine
learning engineering, for example,
machine learning engineering bench, and
we don't quite see that. What about this
benchmark from the system card, OpenAI
pull requests? Can GPT5 do some of the
more mundane tasks that performed at
OpenAI? Well, without diving too much
into that benchmark, notice the
increment. We're not seeing big jumps
from 03. What about the ability of
models to replicate state-of-the-art AI
research? This was tested on OpenAI's
own paper bench. Again, correct me if
I'm wrong, but not a huge step forward.
Then there's this benchmark, arguably
the most interesting of them all. I
actually think it's a brilliant
benchmark and I remember asking someone
at OpenAI about such a benchmark 2 years
ago. Pretty sure that request had no
impact, but either way, check this out.
Can AI models overcome any of 20
internal research and engineering
bottlenecks encountered for real at
OpenAI in the past? These were the kind
of bottlenecks that led to delays of at
least a day and in some cases they said
it influenced the outcome of large
training runs and launches. amazing
benchmark and for now slightly
underwhelming performance. I say that,
but it kind of depends on your
perspective because solving 2% of those
is not bad in my opinion. My only point
was that's the same score as 03. Mind
you, I've just noticed something while
filming. The green bar looks taller than
03's bar, even though it's the same 2%.
Man, the chart crimes that OpenAI are
doing for GBT are unbelievable. I'm just
going to spend 20 seconds now on safety
because I did see OpenAI's safety paper
and while I haven't finished it, I do
love the sound of the new approach on
refusals. Basically, they've moved to
what's called safe completions as a new
safety paradigm. It makes sense to me
because rather than the model just
making a snap judgment, is the user's
intent good or bad? Then completely
obeying or refusing. Instead, safe
completions focuses entirely on the
safety of the model's output.
translating the pages I have read so
far. It's basically, "We don't really
care why you're asking this. This is the
only information we're going to give
you." Perfect segue to the sponsors of
today's video, Grace Swan. Let me know
what you think, but what I find epic is
that you can make all models, not just
OpenAIs, more secure yourself, as in you
watching. I mean, literally, a few of
the viewers of this channel have gone on
to the leaderboards in these paid
competitions. If you are not familiar
with them, you basically have to find
jailbreaks for these models and thereby
improve model security. If you're
interested, do use my personal link in
the description. And for me, models
being less likely to output bioteterror
instructions is just a win-win. Now, for
some last benchmarks before I draw this
first impressions video to an end, GPT5
doesn't quite get the record for what
I'm calling a pattern recognition
benchmark, Arc AGI 2. It's beaten by
Grock 4 which gets 16% compared to its
10%. GPT5 is of course much cheaper
though. Curiously, GPT5 got a new record
on the Google proof science benchmark
called GPQA getting 88.4%.
But they barely mentioned that on the
website or the live stream or the system
card. In 2024, this was one of the most
cited benchmarks for testing model
intelligence. Seeing the open weights
open AAI models score so highly did make
me start to worry about benchmark
maxing. Same story with humanity's last
exam. In other words, if you are new to
the channel and thought a model breaking
records in all sorts of benchmarks meant
it had to be the smartest, then do
please stick around. Now, it seems
fitting as I draw the video to an end
that we should discuss the end of the
model selector because unless you are on
the pro tier, all the other models that
you can see here are deprecated. That's
good news in a way if you like to avoid
that mess of models to select from. Not
as good news if you liked a particular
variant for whatever reason. So there we
are. That's my take on GT5. What is
yours? For me, I must admit it's quite a
poignant moment in the history of this
channel. I've been making videos
touching on what GT5 might be like for
man, it must be over 2 years now. Some
of you watching will have been following
the channel since then and thank you so
much. Would the Philillip of 2 years ago
have been bowled over by the GT5 of
today? I genuinely don't know. Will we
all be bowled over by the GPT6 or 7 of
the future? Only time will tell. Man,
that was kind of a cliche ending, but
forgive me and thank you so much for
watching. Have a wonderful